ich lehne mich jetzt mal ganz ganz weit
aus dem fenster immer noch dumm und kaká
in der tat ihr habt es mal wieder
geschafft meine damen und herren ihr
befindet euch hier auf den bescheuerten
kanal auf youtube
ich habe mich für heute etwas ganz
besonderes überlegt und zwar durch ein
video gefunden was sagt weil ich ist
geistige alter mann hdtv
hey leute und herzlich willkommen bei
wissenswert hey ich bin luca ich möchte
heute mein geistiges alter raus finden
in diesem video werden wir testen wie
hoch sein geistiges alter ist eine
boxershort ist gerade gerissen sind hier
wegen meinem geistigen alter oder wegen
meiner boxershort richtig wir sind hier
wegen dazu gibt es zehn fragen die
jeweils vier antwortmöglichkeiten haben
ok zehn fragen mit jeweils vier
antwortmöglichkeiten
ich werde alles richtig haben also ein
bisschen wie bei wer wird millionär nur
dass wir hier nicht mehr millionär
werden können sondern wir wissen nachher
wie alt wir sind für jede antwort
möglichkeit gibt es allerdings
unterschiedlich viele punkte
es gibt natürlich kein richtig froh wir
haben sogar regeln also zusammengefasst
es werden jetzt gleich zehn fragen
vorkommen und jede frage hat vier
verschiedene antwortmöglichkeiten und
dementsprechend was man ausgewählt hat
dementsprechend viele punkte bekommt man
also es ist jetzt nicht so ein test von
wegen das ist richtig und das ist falsch
so wie ich das bei einem iq test mit
regional gemacht habe ich komme so dumm
von luca
innovative system wow ich brauche zettel
und stifte mit die punkte zu notieren
ein paar sekunden später
ich habe meinen blog geholten stift und
eine brille damit ich zumindest klug aus
der nummer 10 los gehts welchen youtuber
würdest du am ehesten anguckt was a
was ist das für die frage links von der
laden in chf leute freude oder de martin
fischer bocchino ich krieg mal kurz auf
pause was das für eine bescheuerte frage
wieso bestimmt mein geschmack was
youtuber angeht was ich für geistiges
alter habe ja herr wissenswert ev das
ist ja jetzt hier nicht so der sache
muss ich mir erst mal ganz kurz ein paar
notizen machen das und meine notizen
jetzt weiß ich welche news über ich am
liebsten schaue jetzt mal real talk ich
habe wirklich überhaupt keine ahnung was
diese frage hier soll aber es ist halt
die erste frage deswegen welchen
youtuber würdig von denen am ehesten
schauen ich würde sagen paletten weil
der in meinen augen der unterhaltsamste
von in allen ist deswegen nehme ich
vermute mal einfach ein witziger kerl
ist also a wie viele punkte kriege ich
jetzt
wann kommt denn die antworten links hier
wenn du pas luton genommen hast dann
notierte jetzt 40 punkte ok 40 punkte 40
wenn du
felix von der laden genommen hast nur
der 30 punkte okay wenn du leute
genommen hast 20 jahre und bei martin
fischer clavinova zehn punkte alter
jetzt habe ich die meisten heißt das ich
bin werd am ende der dümmste die könnt
ihr auch einfach mal wenn ihr bock habt
ihr den kommentaren mitmachen also
schreibt einfach immer eure punkte auf
alten in den kommentar unter dem video
dann am ende könnte das zusammenziehen
und sagen was euer geistiges alter ist
nummer 9
welche der folgenden gruppen von farben
gefällt
farben haben warum haben als ich aus wie
ein kind wahrscheinlich sich gerade
wirklich ein bisschen aus wie ein
künstler mit meinem blog und der brille
also wir haben ja einmal schwarz grau
braun finde ich sehr trist diese farben
dann haben wir hier so komplett bunte
farben und zu übergänge dann haben wir
bei der c blau grün gelb und bei der die
quasi so ein bisschen pastell bisschen
glattere farben ich würde sagen ich
nehme mal zäh weil also knallige farben
gefallen wenn auch am besten ich habe
jetzt gerade hier auch so ein blaues
stadt und in meinem gestrigen die hatte
ich ein gelbes neongelben shirt an auch
ganz lustig unter meinem gestrigen video
haben einfach voll viele leute drüber
geschrieben ist aus dem textmarker danke
dafür auf jeden fall gibt es 20 punkte
okay für b gibt es 30 bis 40 punkte ich
glaube immer noch dass das total scheiße
ist wenn man so viele punkte hat
wieder 40 für de gabs jetzt um wenigsten
punkte aber wir machen direkt weiterer
sie jung genau mit fracht sind alle
anders und d gehören zum leben dazu
natürlich sind eklig wenn wir jetzt
auswahlmöglichkeiten beziehungen sind
alle anders beziehungen sind aufregend
beziehungen sind eklig oder beziehungen
gehören zum leben dazu ich würde sagen
beziehungen sind alle anders ist
natürlich logisch klar keine beziehung
ist gleich aber beziehungen sind
aufregend finde ich deswegen sage ich
b&b alphabet und zahlen lernen mit luca
fix zu 20 punkte und beziehungen sind
aufreger um hass gibt das 30 30 30 und
bei den beziehungen gehören zum leben
dazu
zehn punkte ich glaube ich war bei den
ersten beiden fragen relativ kacke es
wird safe am ende so sein dass die
person mit dem geringsten punktestand
das höchste geistige alter hut und ich
habe 40 30 aber wir lassen uns davon
nicht unterkriegen wir sind eines der
folgenden gerichte meeresfrüchte
b imbiss essen fast food was gut oder
die suppe suppe ich glaube aber gibt die
wenigsten punkte allerdings hasse ich
das was bei abgebildet ist wer sich
jetzt relativ gern sie fast food naja
oder suppe welcher mensch ist suppe also
wenn ich jetzt wirklich ein gericht
auswählen müsste und dass mein leben
lang jetzt immer essen müsste dann
müsste es mir schon gut schmecken es
würden wegen www.b currywurst currywurst
mit pommes büro aber wenn du das in
dessen genommen hat 30 bei c fastfood 40
und bei de suppe 20 ok trage ich mir 20
punkte freunde 20 in case you can read
write wählen noch ein getränk dazu einen
softdrink also cola limo schreit ja ich
weiß was softdrinks sind
rotwein gibt wahrscheinlich wieder zehn
punkte allerdings hatte ich rotwein
deswegen um mir jetzt mal hier die
auswahlmöglichkeiten wieder so ein
bisschen ins auge zu fassen
wir haben dann für mich noch übrig
softdrinks bier und fruchtsaft bier
trinke ich zum essen nicht so gern
softdrinks sind übels überzuckert und
einfach nur chemie kacke deswegen würde
ich sagen fruchtsaft und damit idee de
wie dick wenn dubé bier genommen hast
dich ja rotwein trinken wahrscheinlichen
punkte und rr10 8 32 punkte können wir
wieder aufschreiben 30 freunde mit dem
er bis heute hier 30 hier aussieht sie
haben die hälfte geschafft wir müssen da
muss man sich ja erstmal ein bisschen
strecken
ich fühle mich schon so wissenswert
wohin würdest du am liebsten reist
disneyland disneyland trier mallorca
mallorca de walle die malediven
ich lehne mich jetzt mal ganz ganz weit
aus dem fenster
ich würde sagen müssen lernen wieder 40
punkte allerdings würde ich echt voll
gerne auf die malediven deswegen sage
ich mal wieder wie dick werden wir zu
genau dieser 40 punkte auch mallorca
wahrscheinlich einen normativen 20 alter
wir kommen gerne wieder runter auf die
normalen zahlen was man daumen hoch da
wenn ich diesen zettel hier verlosen
soll und bei 330 millionen likes verlose
ich dass eine doku ein zeichentrick
bierchen trinkt tee einen action film
oder eine idee ein drama oder manche
leute legen sich da ja auch gewisse
torres fest und schauen sich wirklich
genau nur das an bei mir ist es durch
schau erhalten nur kontrakte weil ich
sage einfach mal action film oder
komödie wenn du dir die doku angucken
würde es gibt das zehn punkte beim
zeichentrickfilm 40 punkte beim
actionfilme oder der komödie 30 punkte
30 was denkst du über süßigkeiten
ich esse unglaublich wenig süßigkeiten
ich das erste mal bei freunden von mir
so wie jetzt immer hier grad essen hier
etwas süßes oder dann im kino
von vielen autos und noch irgendwie
gummibärchen dazu ich bin irgendwie
überhaupt nicht so einen menschen nicht
ernähre mich eigentlich echt bewusst
gesund so weit ich es dann kann deswegen
würde ich sagen
süßigkeiten sind ungesund weil das ist
die wahrheit wenn du denkst dass es nur
etwas für kinder 20 punkte und wenn du
sie für ungesund hält zehn wochen meine
erste 10 was denkst du über soziale
medien interessant sie sind nützliche
12b zeitverschwendung hat verschwendete
ich mache mich nicht ohne und oder die
verwirrend boah das ist ja so schwierig
hier mein komplettes abi und mein
komplettes bachelor studium war nichts
ging dieses diesem test also meinem fall
ist es ja noch mal ein bisschen was
anderes weil ich ja mein geld mehr oder
weniger mit youtube verdiene also mit
den sozialen medien deswegen würde ich
sagen ich kann nicht ohne bei der c aber
sonst würde ich sagen irgendwie nützlich
oder zeitverschwendung wenn du denkst
soziale medien sind zeitverschwendung
die aus 20 20 wenn du nicht ohne leben
könnte ist dann sind das 40 punkte 40
verdammte kacke das würdest du mit zehn
millionen euro machen als spenden drei
einen freizeitpark kaufen okay sie eine
villa kaufen und die vielseitig
investieren
ist relativ easy wenn ich zehn millionen
euro auf die gerade bekommen würde
meine kamera
ich würde ein teil davon spenden
allerdings auch viel vielseitig
investieren von daher würde ich sagen
die idee für dich wenn du einen
freizeitpark auf würde ist 40 ja bei
einer villa 30 und wenn du sie
vielseitig investieren würden mit 20 20
nun hast du einige sekunden zeit um
deine punkte zusammen zu zählen und dann
kommen wir allmählich zur auflösung okay
dann zähle ich erst mal zusammen 2000
jahre später
260 punkte habe ich zusammen das bin ich
bin 16 bis 21 und ich bin sogar 21 also
es macht sogar sinn
das war es jetzt in familie meine damen
und herren ihr könnt ihr einfach morgen
in die kommentare schreiben was ihr für
eine punktzahl hatte
jetzt kommt er wieder diese drei mal
klugen und schreiben jetzt in den
kommentaren von zehn fragen hat sich 100
punkte ich bin geistig 5 milliarden
jahre alt wollte dass sich häufiger
solche tests machen weil es gibt noch
viel viel mehr von solchen tests einem
schreibt auch noch in die kommentare
lasten leichter wenn ihr dieses tolle
bild hier